Harry Styles and Olivia Wilde are taking
some time apart after nearly two years
of dating
we've learned the couples taking a break
the news comes as Harry prepares for the
overseas leg of his Harry's house
concert tour
[Music]
and as Olivia focuses on her two kids
with ex Jason Sudeikis eight-year-old
Otis and six-year-old Daisy it just
makes me realize how lucky I am and one
report says it's these different
priorities that are keeping them apart
[Music]
the pair first sparked romance rumors in
2020 right around the time that Olivia
and Jason called off their engagement
and when cameras rolled on don't worry
darling Olivia's second film as director
Harry the leading man our life together
to lose this
it's the easiest place to fall in love
you fell in love on a movie set oh
how to answer this question I had a
wonderful experience being directed by
Olivia you have to trust a lot requires
a lot of trust if you want to give it
everything and I think being able to
trust your director is a gift and
there's been no shortage of headlines
ever since that's right that is right
whether it was rumored onset feuds it's
too bizarre suspiciously timed custody
papers and of course spit gate she did
not but I think it's a perfect example
of like people will look for drama
anywhere they can both stars have a lot
on their plates right now Harry juggling
careers in music and film and Olivia is
reportedly directing perfect a biopic
about Olympic gold medalist Carrie
struck but as for their love lives guess
you could say things are no longer
foreign
[Music]